a historic Summit aimed at addressing
reparations for the transatlantic slave
trade has come to a close in Bridgetown
Barbados cause Preparatory Justice uh
and just 21st century is the highest
point and the rise of the global
democracy movement
the week-long meeting was a first of its
kind incorporating leading voices from
reparations movements in Africa the
Caribbean Europe and the Americas this
means so much to us this is what we have
struggled for for these past hundreds of
years and this is the moment this 21st
century where we are now galvanized
around this matter
among the most notable guests at the
summit was Colombian vice president
Francia Marquez I'd like to ask about
the challenges that lie ahead we asked
her about the challenges facing the
reparations movement especially those
pertaining to racism and white Supremacy
This Racist system that is destroying
the planet isn't willing to give back
because it causes discomfort to talk
about preparations above all it's
uncomfortable to question the privilege
that has been gained through the blood
and suffering of thousands upon
thousands of human beings
one of the most concrete steps taken by
delegates of this Summit was the
establishment of a legal framework on
slavery reparations that could soon be
presented before International courts
delegates however were careful not to
divulge the details of any upcoming
International litigation we all what we
advocate for its right and due process
and we will take our actions as far as
the jurisprudence to follow all the
legal actions in features in years to
come
the island of Barbados has become a
leader within the international effort
on reparative Justice for the
descendants of enslaved persons since
2012 the country's National task force
on reparations has been working to
develop a multilateral approach for
gaining international support as the
reparations movement continues to gain
momentum Advocates say the next steps
are turning this topic into a global
conversation Barbados